[Music]
hey guys just yesterday the newest
season 8 informational eked george RR
martin was offered cameo in the final
episodes of the series but he turned it
down some fans claim disinformation
debunks the most popular end game theory
old Sam being the narrator of Game of
Thrones
we told his events being written in his
book a lot of fans also believe it's
just the opposite it confirms the story
being true that's what we are going to
discuss in this video the steerer got
very popular quite a long time ago while
also introduced with the idea of george
RR martin playing gold Sam at the end as
he finishes reading his own books this
theory gained even more popularity when
an actor who plays similarly spilled
some spoilers during one interview many
fans circle means that Bradley gave away
a big spoiler and it's about his
character Sam surviving to the end let's
take a look on the clip I feel exactly
the same every year we've gone back and
we put that skin on again and we and
we've become those characters again and
Sam it may be a very painful part to
play with a lot of pain in it and a lot
of heartache in there but it was always
a nice place to go back to to kind of
touch base with him again and just see
how he is and just to think that I'm
never gonna I feel like I'm abandoning
him can I go because I'm never gonna see
how he is again and I just hope that
funny enough they become real people and
you just hope that they're happy but to
know that you're never gonna touch base
with them again and you just kind of
left them to do their own thing it's
kind of hard it's emotionally a real
emotional separation I think Bradley
said it'll be hard not going back to
check on the character Sam he feels like
he's abandoning him what this means is
that his character survives the game of
Thrones and it's hard for him to know
that he's never again going back in game
internals to check on Sam and his life
after season 8 is over if Sam died it
would not be hard for him to never go
back to check on the character in fact
if Sam guys barely could not even check
on him and see how he's doing
also Bradley would not feel like he's
abandoning Sam if Sam was not alive
after season 8 so there's that although
to be honest most of us have expected
him to survive and now it's confirmed
Sam survives the game of Thrones does
this ultimately spoil that a living
valve a knee
up to you to decide for yourself but in
my opinion it's definitely not spoiling
the outcome of the Great War this
revelation however besides spoiling
faith of similarly might also stand as a
confirmation of a popular event your
image same is actually the one narrating
the game of Thrones
thus he has to survive the events of
game turns to be able to narrate it over
a year ago I introduced with this your
image the story of Game of Thrones has
already been written down and is this
whole time being narrated by similarly
in the previous season hinted at big
time before I show you a strong hint
from season 7 episode 2 that is going
favor to this theory let me first
briefly introduce you the whole thing
about same being the narrator of Game of
Thrones basically I came up to this
theory while reading John Brady's
interviews an actor that portrays
similarly in series rarely came up with
the theory based on the object in the
game of Thrones opening credits that is
identical to Diaz he said gyroscope this
is hanging inside a citadel John Bailey
theorized and might have even figured
out the game of transcending Bradley
said I think it could mean any number of
things one theory is that what we are
seeing now and having experiencing a
material since I'm telling the story of
Game of Thrones if you take the logic of
the story now the story of Westeros and
the story of the battle for the Iron
Throne it would be a book in that
library the visual motif of that is
you're about to be told the story the
sense of an idea being told a story and
people gaining the knowledge the way Sam
is absorbing knowledge in the library
this is a great theory when you look at
it each and every episode of Game of
Thrones is sorry the same way ever since
the show began with the same opening
credits well we have always been
wondering what one particular object
that looks like mechanical son is the
origin of this and one more object was
finally revealed in season six finale
Sam finally entered the library and
there it is chandelier looking
attraction that looks exactly like the
Esther Leafs an object from the opening
credits that have been watching for
seven years in all 67 episodes
what's the purpose of this chandelier
looking at rap scene in Citadel just as
it looks like at first glance one of its
functions is reflects sunlight from the
window high above around the room over
mirrors because the Masters who use then
maintain the library would never ask him
in candles anywhere near books however
the most important function of Esther
Lape or more accurately armillary sphere
is to locate and predict positions of
the stars and planets in order to
provide local time and more these
functions of the tremendous importance
for the Masters of the Citadel as it
helps them to determine when the long
seasons of Westeros officially begin an
end about which day then informed
castles and cities of the Seven Kingdoms
by standing out white Raymond's to share
the news
in this theory however D s truly been a
changing map Oh Westeros that we see
before every single episode represent
the unfolding of a story being told by
Sam himself as it can be seen the
creator so the title sequence decided to
place the map on the inner surface of a
sphere at the nest reliefs an object at
the center the camera would then visit
different parts of the map while
illustrations on yes relate covered some
of the backstory to the show as we all
know the game of Thrones title sequence
introduces every episode and changes
depending on the locations visited in
that particular episode the opening
credits consist of a three-dimensional
map of the world with the continents of
Westeros and Essos located on the inner
surface of a sphere at the center of the
spheres light source effectively a Sun
surrounded by an s really black
arrangement of rotating rings the
sequence opens with a close-up of the
Sun and the S relieves surrounding it
well the most interesting parts are to
relieve details they're visible on the
astrolabe in both Game of Thrones
opening credits and in world's greatest
library since those store actually the
same object really details on the table
jacket are showing a volcano destroying
a city while dragon watch is on and
several people escaping in a boat a
reference to the doom of Valyria and the
Targaryen escape from it after a few
moments there's another closeup of the
detail on yesterday but this time
showing the stark direwolf lynnster lion
Baratheon stag engaging the Targaryen
dragon in combat reference to Robert's
rebellion the less close-up of the
relief detail on the astrolabe which is
also the ending of the title sequence is
now showing the animals representing the
various noble houses of Westeros bowing
to the victorious Baratheon stag the
Game of Thrones logo then appears
overlaid with the heads of a dragon wolf
lion and a stag emerging from the side
of the logo season 6 provided us one
more proof that is going favor to this
theory when same arrives at the Citadel
he is greeted by maester who uses a
distinctive pair of glasses to read the
text in front of him those glasses to be
exact its lenses feature most probably
seen in each episode of gaming journals
in the opening credits as you can see in
every title sequence while zooming in on
city of King's Landing and while zooming
out of the wall the map is actually seen
through lenses that appeared to be just
like those glasses now let's see how
this theory might have been confirmed or
least hinted in season 7 well our
schmitz rebels and Sam were gathering
books in the cetera library archmaester
said the line that seems to be a strong
hint for central being the narrator of
Game of Thrones epic fan is now also
Song of Ice and Fire which was later
adapted into the HBO series game
internals most certainly does sound more
poetic this marks the biggest Kindle
Game of Thrones series my 10 we told Sam
looking up
because he finally reads the whole story
this would mean that all the events that
we've seen and all the events that we're
about to see had already taken place and
they were actually written in cents book
that he is reading to someone don't you
think George are Martin would fit
perfectly as the old Sam who is looking
up from book as he finally reads the
whole story to either little Sam or John
and Danish child or even to both of them
well this would be Martin's first
appearance in Game Jones it most
certainly would not be the first time
the showrunner decided to pay their
respect towards George tried the show
even though this will be the most
important and the most noticed one in
fact the show runners already mentioned
George are Martin and his genius mind
several times for the show I'm sure
there are a few mangas the remember
Mockingbird the blue-eyed giant is
according to some stories investors
reason why the sky is blue is according
to legend an entire known world is a
tiny object floating in the eye of
Macomber however in A Song of Ice and
Fire novels there's no legend about the
sky being bloom because the entire world
is in the eye of a blue-eyed giant named
Macomber nor any comparable fable but as
being said it's pretty easy to conclude
that may embrace a meta-narrative
reference to the author george RR martin
since the entire fictional universe
originated inside of his head
george RR martin was already supposed to
play a role in Game of Thrones when he
filmed a cameo appearance in unaired
pilot episode of Game of Thrones as a
background pentoshi merchant came in
minded he was already supposed to appear
in the series george RR martin between
gold Sam in the last scene of gammatron
series most early doesn't seem to be out
of the realm of possibilities
additionally during one interview Martin
said that if he was in the story he'd
probably be similarly he's a great
character Martin said tyrion might be
who I want to be but Sam is probably
closer to who actually am the fat kid
who likes to read books and doesn't like
to go up a lot of stairs long story
short is B Hinton and for share of that
game appearance would end up with an old
same looking from the book as here
finishes reading or writing all the
events the only problem fans have with
the story of Sam being the narrator of
Game of Thrones would be its credibility
if all of this for events written in
Sam's book can really believe everything
that's been told to us artist arcs
really the good ones and their Delaney's
are surely the villains of the story
what fans are trying to say is that
Sam's look and events could be biased or
the Starks and Jon Snow and therefore
defense might have not happen exactly as
we've been told
however if this theory does in fact come
true if gimmick on Julian's we told Sam
narrating the VMAs Jones to someone with
george RR martin when training him I can
tell you for a fact that we can believe
that all the events happened just like
it's been told to us without sending by
towards the Starks in John snow how do
we even know that Sam even knows exactly
all the events when he's not even been
most of them for example how about same
know the conversation between some
characters when he's not even been
anywhere close to them well he has brain
the only person who could gone back in
time and see whatever Sam asked him to
see which is exactly what happened in
season seven months Ms Brown to check if
the marriage between Rhaegar Targaryen
and Lyanna stark actually happened in
conclusion this John Braley's theory
that support with view proves definitely
sound interesting and after all what
better way to end the game Eternals then
with george RR martin himself the one
who created this world in the first
place however the latest isn't a news
left hands convinced that this theory
will not come true yesterday george RR
martin confirmed that he will not appear
in season 8 but he also confirmed that
the showrunners invited him to a cameo
in one of the final episodes in my
opinion this doesn t bunk this theory in
fact i believe it confirms it the
showrunner see mighty George to do cameo
in one of the final episodes most likely
to play in old sin with Georgia Martin
turning down an offer someone else will
play in old sin the showrunners probably
just like a story will be very cool to
have George himself playing an old same
who wrote all these events of Game Jones
but apparently George does not feel the
same what do you guys think is this new
season a leaked information confirming
this very popular theory or is it
debunking it let me know in the comment
section down below and as always I hope
you guys enjoyed this video if you did
please make sure to subscribe to our
Channel and I hope to see you in the
next one peace